welcome thank you all for coming I'm
delighted to welcome and introduce each
seat on the speaker tonight Eve is
currently a professor literature and
visiting professor at this semester at
NYU and at Harvard University
Akemi figured out to get to be big witty
of eve is the author easy tolls the
number is the author of a number of
books and a great many articles I
mentioned just a few titles the first
book which came out every sauce on
political power and sexual impotence
personal failure defiles great friends
great defiance which is a fantastic book
on literature power and sexuality but if
has published on et century economic
theory he's published a great book on
Spinoza in the 18th century imagine in a
cold oven I developed a spindle in
French enlightenment which came out in
2006 and more recently I want to mention
two books which has come out in the last
few years one is the identity actually a
book what is it you betta publish the
damn stuff
which is I mean as strongly recommended
to all of you it's a fantastic book on
the practice of literary reading and the
practice of literary interpretation
today the importance of the practice of
literary interpretation today begins
with a response to remarks by politician
it's a wonderful and latest book I
believe that knew that nearly humanity
which came out Atlantica birth which is
also a spirited defense literary studies
couple studies the humanities in general
and I believe it was reviewed through
many a and today my mouth which is a
feet and positively renewed in both
these these publications and I want to
add that ec2 is also jazz critic jazz
enthusiast jazz and then he is also one
of the editors of the journal meaty tune
the images were out just a minute ago
which to my mind is one of the most
engaging
cultural political Germans coming out
here today and which is published so in
hardcopy but four times a year in
hardcopy but also online
they're waiting for
it comes from here if there's any
mistake responsible trash he knows more
about cinematic images than I do but I'm
interested in you people maybe hopefully
not as many as she deserves because
originally I thought something on the
cinnamon I realize everybody's doing
something intelligence another something
very good that some of you who are here
maybe for a couple weeks ago with a
smelly and an attorney so I changed my
talk and the focus of single-loop who
has a link with dollars which is that
when you see she does talk about
individuation very often this person
Gianna so but I won't mention donors
today I will organize my presentation
about 4550 minutes in number of
publicity three parts one sort of
introduction in three parts with this
author called defender about shall
defend
18th century even more unknown than GPS
segundo whose only claim to fame is to
have invented photography half a century
before he was invented so you'll see
that he really invented but did
something interesting with it there's a
few quotes from multipaths famous
article we have our ontology of
photographic image probably you've read
a little bit of a so I will give you a
few very fast boats move to water bath
also there's two three quotes from from
Bath on photography so that'll be the
first part then the floor of my
presentation will be just quote
hopefully everybody has their hand out
with the whole second page is full of
course that I translated from 100 by CBC
mode over them what I'm really
interested in presenting today and at
the horizon telling you now to raise the
stakes
what I'm interested in taking back in
photography history of the reverberation
of photography ng desmondo
from a slightly different perspective
the analog image versus digital image
specialists but I think maybe these
readings getting shared a certain
lighting so first part brief history of
the ontology of the photography image
and I'll explain that word fascism very
very soon my first stop is 1760 1760 an
unknown physician from the north of
Redfern Norman Norman he publishes a
book called see 40 and she 40 as you can
see it's an anagram of defense the
bookies are sorry but we can guess it's
come from this person shot if Angela
Hodge born in 1722 then in 1774 and in
this book she 14
so people say starting from 1850 and so
does Wikipedia say I found that we go
he supposedly invented photography
give you the excerpt who is supposed to
have invented photography i just situate
them saying that this novel of shivaji
is the narration of a traveler who is
carried up in the air and lands in an
island in the middle of the desert so is
in Africa in Africa it's a desert and
this is in the desert his querida he
wakes up in this place country 40 which
is inhabited by elementary spirits so
they are invisible beings floating in
the air who happened to be among us so
you should imaging our room here filled
with elementary spirit and the Isle of
XI 40 is where they go to rest like a
vacation resort and in his travel in g4t
the narrator discover all kind of
technological devices while he is
working in this place which is a desert
he are the service agreement that and he
asks his this guy I thought were in the
desert how come I can see the sea how
come I can see a storm at sea and the
answer by the prefab derivative
administrator
you have the elementary spirits
continued the river are not so able
painters as naturalist we shall judge by
their way of work you know that the rays
of light reflected from different bodies
made the picture and paint the bodies
among all polished surfaces on the
retina of the eye for instance on water
on glass mirror glass these are the AMA
tree spirits have studied to fix these
transient images they have composed a
most subtle matter very viscous and
proper to harden and dry by the help of
which the picture is made in the twinkle
of an eye they in the matter spirits do
over with this manner a piece of canvas
and hold it before the objects they have
a mind to build the first effect of the
canvas is that of a mirror there are
seen upon it all the bodies far and near
whose image the light can transmit but
what the glass cannot do the canvas by
means of the viscous matter retains the
images the mirror shows the objects
exactly but keeps number or canvases
show them with the same exactness and we
take them all this impression of the
images is made the first instance they
are received on the fan
which is immediately immediately carried
away into some dark place an hour after
the subtle matter drives and and you
have a picture so much the more valuable
as it cannot be imitated by art not
damaged by time we take in their purest
source in the luminous bodies the colors
which painters extract from different
materials and which time never fails to
alter the justness of the design the
true the thick of the expression the
gradation of the shades the stronger or
weaker strokes the rules of perspective
all these we need to nature with a sure
and never airing hand draws upon
canvases image which images which
deceive the eye and make reason to doubt
whether what are called real objects are
not phantom which imposed upon the side
hearing the feeling and other senses at
once one last quote so he looks at it
for a while and is fascinated meanwhile
I couldn't I take off my eyes from the
pictures a sensible spectator who from
the shore behold a tempest you see is
not more likely impressions such images
are equivalent to the things themselves
the prefect interrupted my basis so I
want from this school in 1760 so about
fifty years before more more than a
century before for the brat were
actually produced for feature of East
description and what I find interesting
in this other typical Amish it's not so
much that he has intuition about
technologies which will happen he was
not the only one to foresee things like
that but it's the way he already sees or
into its consequences of this and these
consequences
I suggest or for me first what's
characteristic of that Valley
photography even if it's an anachronism
is it's
automaticity physical impressions by the
Razorbacks themselves by nature by the
things themselves it's a representation
we have the intermediation of human
subjectivity
so otherwise second point often deceived
such images are equivalent to the things
themselves who who seem similar the
neutrino the charge of reality it is
reality itself that paints itself on
these surfaces and these are authentic
images they are just like the things
themselves the third feature I introduce
a word taken from Loyola
in the history of science and making us
think differently about modernity but we
would like to propose is to use these
terms of fact ish in the English teacher
in English fact ish and when the package
is the mixture of a fact and the finish
and we're all actual general view is
that modernity built itself by opposing
on the one side facts we mothers we
civilized people we advanced people we
have the technology we have science
technology and science are based on
facts in fact savage primitive people
they believe in strange gods they're
superstitious they believe in finishes
and from the 18th century on modernity
was built on this dichotomy either you
know fat and regulator and its knowledge
is not a matter of belief its knowledge
and it's not produced by you nature is
in fact in your modern or your primitive
your free modern and you believe in God
and finishes which we modern know are
produced by men they fabricated these
fetishes these God these idols and so
forth
now lateral wants us to be to to see
that these dichotomy losers we can't
operate and we think we operate like
that if you don't if you
and later what I'm interested in is this
notion of us having to deal with a
mixture of the fact and the fish and in
through the different readings that we
propose to you and we'll see either the
photograph is both the fact and so in
defender about we just saw that sketch
when he said photograph make reasoned
out whether real objects are not
phantoms photograph transforms reality
into something which between us we don't
know what is real everything becomes
maybe an illusion everything becomes
maybe fabricated petrodollars also talks
a lot about seriously life simulator at
the end of the gold remember is in
ecstasy so photographic as described
before it was invented by a defender
lavash shows it as non-human reality
painting itself and as casting a doubt
of the reality of
and smite use of the name fact each
taken from the last thing appears very
delicately here is when he talks about
phantom what I'm interested in following
readings is to add a fourth feature the
fact that photography has to do with
leading death so I don't know much about
history apparently it took things from
the internet this is supposed to be one
of the first entries photography goes in
trains instead on the apps view from the
window at neva arounds 1826 and this is
supposed to be the first human self
portrait from the use of more than half
a century after narration now I'm
getting better charted territory
especially an article by only Bazza so
who died
19:58 and the articles from 1945 about
the ontology about the photography image
and I'm going to take my four categories
and just remind you of what Basner says
in this article which is the same
category as for automaticity for the
first time an image of the wall so he's
describing what changes with the advent
of photography for the first time an
image of the world is formed
automatically without the creative
intervention of man
it's charged by rigorous determinism
this production by automatic means has
radically affected or psychology of the
image know something technology it
changes the way the images were we
relate to reality and to believe or
don't believe in reality the objective
nature photography confers on it
equality of credibility absent from all
other picture
readability authenticity the photograph
as such and the object in self share a
common being after the fashion of a
fingerprint so the model behind this
would be that a fingerprint photograph
is just like a fingerprint where for
photography actually contribute
something to the order of natural
creation instead of providing a
substitute for it just give the idea of
photographic imprint as this notion of
practice is about a fact each the
picture the photograph in fact ish see
we can find it in also he's talking
about surrealism he makes a more general
statement we should not consider the
aesthetic purpose and the mechanical
effect of the image on our imaginations
as things apart it is spending purpose
of the mechanical effect of the image
our imaginations should be thought of
together the logical distinction between
what is imaginary and what is real tends
to disappear
every image is to be seen as an object
and every object as an image things are
equivalent images are two things lasting
but it produces an image that is reality
that is a reality of nature namely
better and hallucination that is also a
fact the photograph is an hallucination
then is also a fact
magnifico in fact and fetishes I think
now last thing which will become even
stronger with bat my next reading which
is already here in better
this essay by person is very short but
obsessed with corpses with traces left
by dead people photography carries the
disturbing presence of lives haunted and
asset movements in the duration
photography just fixes alive and yet
and we have the way to treats
photography is in direct English four
categories I have what is the trademark
of a photography for bad in French I did
this what this has been this to place
this was really sad indeed
as you may know if you read some camera
lucida that is obsessed with the
relation between photography and death
what photography reproduces infinitely
only to play only to place once of each
subject that is photograph I can say
that it or he or she will die
we say who is about to be executed he
says this photo is beautiful so is the
boy this is the studio content if you
want
the picture but the totem is what
punctures works it touches us what
affects us he is going to die
I read simultaneously this has been it's
from a previous century and this will be
it's about to be executed photography
tells me about death in the future what
tortures me is this equivalence another
picture so he's talking about another
photographing of his mom but looking at
the photograph of my mother as a child I
tell myself she will die
I should have to think of a catastrophe
which has already taken place he writes
these texts just after his mother died
whether the person is already dead or
not
any photograph is this catastrophe this
passage from being alive to be dead
either already done or it will happen
money seems to me to
illustrate very well why a photograph
can be or is often a effective both in
fact in the factors this is the fact
what Allah and his mommy were taken at
some point in their history and yet if
you think you are that kid this is more
than the fact this is the fact that
somebody that your mom was holding you
in your arm and you're holding on to her
yes it's a fact but he has to be
something else than the fact and I think
the categorical finish was pretty well
now this having been said I can to you
both
since eyes you you don't work and all
the more because I translated the
excerpt from the booth which has Ali
translated into English so these are my
translation whatever in water
we haven't been exposed to
with the Gotti to make you understand
how a single dog takes these problems
and we trace them and I think so similar
people know mostly because he had some
influence on $10 he wrote two major
books one of them is in French German
existence the subject technique 1958 on
the mode of existence of technique of
the mode of existence of technical
objects techniques one of the great
thinking about techne city very
different from Heidegger and from what
we used to read about technology and I
mean very powerful so that's one of the
main contribution is this 58 book on
Tecna city and another one is hero to
this presentation to thesis is other
thesis on theory of individuation it's
the best cure or the best antidote
against or sort of latent individualism
or we are individuals and when we voted
me voting 3d form so sort of the way the
others understand individuals is as
processing there are no such things as
individuals there are processes of
individuation and all
psychological level collective level
social level forever and he helps us
understand these processes of
individuation
I need that aside for now I'm going to
concentrate all my quotes on one book
that was very recently published two
years ago I think which is a course that
singleton gave in 65 66 on imagination
and invention and what I'm interested in
the quotes I will give you deal with
this issue what is an image within
Simonov system and how does it operate
what its power
what's its agency now first thing you
have to understand is that what Simone
allows an image has three different
phases and if you understand that many
okay so I'm going to take some time to
go over these the first phase we usually
don't see the
but it's crucial to understand it's a a
priori phenomenon before you even see an
image there is something in you which
see 100 cows sensorimotor
tendencies sensorimotor Tennyson -
example first one is all of us we were
born at some point before we knew what
was a bottle before we had an image of a
bottle of a nipple of anything we came
with this I see I think we wouldn't be
here if we didn't come with this so
before there was an interaction between
our body and some object in the world
there was a sensory motor tendency which
is to open your mouth and to suck I
guess that's what we do so that's the
leader Zeta I'm trying to explain when
senses is a bit cryptic sometimes if I
show you this an exchange between light
your eyes your sister and so forth
you recognize it's a pen or a pencil now
before I show you the bed there was
something in you if you're a
right-handed person that knowing that
you take a pen like this with your right
hand or with your left hand or some
people take it like this or something
there is pre-existent to sing this very
bad there is something in you
which some would call a priori a
sensorimotor tendency which is that you
use bend
instead of in in order to write so there
is something physical that comes from
you geared towards action that
pre-exists looking at this particular
bit that's the first phase of the image
for Simona
the second phase is much more intuitive
it's the exchange that you have between
your eyes and this so it's a moment of
contact between you a perceiving subject
and this material object and the
stimulation of information realizes
black supposed to read if you looking
closely there will be some defect here
is half full so you learn things in an
exchange of information with the object
traditional perception third phase is
also not that surprising memories I'll
hide my pen and you have a certain
memory today because you're not very
interested of what you saw in Japan it's
black and so far so in simple word you
could say it comes a posteriori after
the exchange and interaction with the
object and its effectively charged
increase think that are printed in you
which the subject carries with him on
her after the encounter with the object
and you see that in three phases are
organized in such
in the first one you are geared towards
an action rhyming sake doing something
second phase is an assimilation of
information between you and the object
third phase see model says and I won't
develop that but that's most of it look
actually if you want to know question
right so we can go into that
the third phase is memories it's a
matter of reconfiguring the information
that you've just committed so three
phases for and the image is out of these
three things it's not just one it's not
Phase two of these three the image is
the fact that these three phases are all
necessary for an image to exist in human
beings now in order to explain what
images are see model also goes back to
the origin of the word symbol symbol
goes back to the Greek and so you may
know that in Greek simpler meant one
something like that the piece of
ceramics that what were they explain sir
single are like these these pieces of
ceramics which travelers in antiquity
split into
before leaving their host and at which
they kept to have their offspring in
order to revive and authenticate the
relations of hospitality would bring
their half of the broken piece would
present it in front of the other half in
order to reconstitute the broken unity
so a similar image of you in something
like basically an ID card or again
fingerprint it's a way of marking
identity by taking a piece of ceramic
breaking it you keep one half and
there's another half somewhere in the
world that will fit background and it
comes back to me you are the son of that
person who thirty years ago came and had
an exchange of hospitality with me as we
disappear see my three phases otherwise
are slow you have three phases yogig
cool thanks do not stop
so similarly Dennis images what happens
in these three phases of the image is
the building of the symbol in our head
and images are symbol and that we keep
in mine we will name symbols these
images is memory image memories which
result from an intense exchange between
the subject and a situation the first
phase we don't just encounter images
like this Rahl is doing something we're
always worried about something we always
invest effects and desires and appetites
and action in this and it is within this
context of activity of agency that we
encountered images so memories which
result from that they result from some
form of exchange and often intense
exchange between a subject and not just
objects for the situation having
strongly participated in an action in a
situation the subject has given
something of himself to this reality
conversely he retains an image dense
enough to be like a fragment of the
reality of the situation like a symbol
of like something
Rodan each time you live the moment you
build a relation or a situation and when
you keep the memory it's a broken part
of that situation of that relation that
you carry with you
but there's another broken part of it
which was this reality conversely it
retains an image that's enough to be
like a fragment of the reality of the
situation which allows you to reactivate
it with this broken partner that you
have in your mind you can recover
reactivated some of the situation such
is the memory of the fights but a great
danger of a house in which one has been
so a charter reality coming from the
situation the real situation is carried
by the image in order to refer to that I
will suggest we use the word relation
relation to a situation you are part of
a situation and you keep a part of this
reality real situation in you in the
form of elimination
hence images have an objective right
they're not just a subjective reality
they have an objective form of life they
exist
not necessarily independently but as I
said they cannot be governed by our
subjectivity or or desire freedom they
are part of this situation which was
exterior to us and we keep a bit of this
exteriority in our mind as we work with
these images images can only be governed
in an indirect manner they keep a
certain capacity like a foreign
population within a well-organized state
you will go back to this I requires like
organism so we have to think of images
as something that lives in us they live
in us there something exterior that live
in us that we can use you can mobilize
but they resist to or attempted or
desires and they invade us or the
occupiers just like an army can
the country containing a certain measure
of will appetites and movement images
almost appear as secondary organisms
within the thinking being against the
unity of the person they can be a seed
of duplication make you schizophrenic
but they can also greet the reserve of
their power and implicit knowledge when
problems need to be solved you have bits
of reality in you that you can use in
order to solve the problem this
dimension both objective and subjective
of the images can response to the status
of quasi organism which the images
possesses inhabiting within the subject
and developing itself in him with
relative independence towards his
unified conscious activity this
objective existence of the image and
this agency that images have within us
they are short of reality and the
resistance due to the
nests of the image witness meaning they
come from the real situation the
childhood reality carried by this image
makes them for the consumer no resist
against our free will
it makes them refuse to let themselves
be directed by or will to present
themselves according to their own forces
inhabiting consciousness again like it
was the organism like an intruder who
disturbs the order of the house in which
is not invited hence the power of an
image comes from its relation from the
fact that it is an imprint symbol
resulting from a concrete relation
let me go more into this idea of a
charge of reality which was summarized
with similar when states will follow
these three phases and now what is an
image receivable this since this is made
of an equal proportion of energen motor
energy recall earlier sensory motor
tendency you always relate to images
with things to do or with things to want
or with things to be afraid of
so first you have their appetite your
desires your fears your effects and this
is how you have pretend the images so
the senses this comes in equal
proportion from this motor energy
sensory motor tendencies that come from
your phase 1 of information coming from
the environment the contact with the
object itself and this becomes a
concrete symbol symbol and we're talking
about of the relation between the
subject and his environment this
particular mix and that's phase 3 memory
represents a point of insertion of or
mental activity in our environment the
memory Ricky
every memory so you can prove the
particular mix phase three memory
represents the point of insertion of our
mental activity in our environment it
condenses a situation it conserves it
with its network of forces and tendency
what is the situation is a network of
forces and tendencies and if this
network for some tendencies which is
condensed and conserved in the image
that inhabits or mind and it makes it
possible to recall it this network for
some tendencies and
I just say few times the same as
anything no I know faster yeah no I just
now these images if you follow minions
you know go on how to understand them
they propagated propagate in various
forms that's what we can see the occupy
it's like an army of the invaders
organism juice and intermediary reality
between the abstract and the concrete
and that's crucial images are
intermediaries between subjective
objective between abstract and country
between the ego and the world
the image is not only events of
realities so far as you said words in
order to know for - yes it is in our
mind but it's also materializes outside
it materializes its institutionalizes
itself it becomes a product a commodity
in spreads to commercial networks and
through the mass media which broadcasts
information once they are materialized
and objectified images constitute the
charge and command chart of reality and
command attention which partially
determines social development one
example that Cyrano takes is the
circular causality that revolves around
clichs and stereotypes
Malthus with my example would be there's
a cliche you think maybe the Switzerland
is a clean country so when you go to
Switzerland you tend to pay attention to
it being more less clean you perceive
differences when you go to Turkey or
Alaska maybe you don't think about it
because you haven't been geared to pay
attention to cleanliness so when you
return you pay attention to this
you think all Switzerland is a clean
country so you alter your attitudes and
your behavior usually you throw your
cigarette butts in the street in
Switzerland you want all my trash to
tell me which has as a result that less
cigarette butts are thrown in the street
these behaviors create a situation which
is that Switzerland is clean and when
other people come to Switzerland the
perception is that 13 country now Maryna
in turbulence which people are not clean
it's just because our foreigners who
come to Switzerland think it is clean
behave as if it should be kept clean
that it ends up in the reality
but we'll show you how just the mental
image realizes itself on materialized
itself in behavior again phase one and
phase two or three three are intimately
connected and how images are more than
just mental we are now one thing I
images in order to make choices choices
with images as an intermediary between
the abscissa time between the abstract
and the concrete the subjective
objective that you go in the world so
well as an intermediary between the
abstract and concrete the images
synthesizes a few feature in a few
features sorry motor cognitive and
affective charges we've seen that
already that's why it makes choice
possible since each image River as a
symbol has a broken part of a situation
which within which were giving each
image has a certain weight a certain
force and since one can weigh and
compare images but what cannot waive or
compare concepts or perceptions as well
we abstract thinking concepts work as a
break as a means of refusal I will do
this because it's not ethical because
for some conceptual reading so concept
of reasons are good to prevent us from
doing a number of these abstract
thinking calculates and reveals
inconvenience inconveniences remote
consequences preventing perceptions on
the other perception they lead us to be
carried away by the situation we are
part of a situation with them to be
carried away by it only the image only
the image has a potential for regulation
since it is abstract enough to detach
the subject from the grip of the
situation is abstracted very we have
this broken part of a symbol in our mind
and we work from that broken far enough
from the situation itself
we are little bit advanced and yet it
allows us to choose because it is
concrete enough to provide a trustworthy
sample of reality that is something we
get it is part of reality which is in or
mine has this broken symbol now if we
have more time I would go into the
fourth phase of the image force model
which is the face of invention imagine
an amount you so far we discussed the
image similar is very interested in the
fourth phase which is the fact that in
these image memories they coexist within
our mind as individual or within our
collective mind within a society these
images which inhabit the subject
collective or individual subject
interact with each other they feel sort
of pressure to be compatible with each
other so they are recombined in more or
less original manners they mutate during
this process and this is this process of
coexistence compatibility comfrey
mutation reorganization recombination of
memories in our
individual and collective mind which
explains our invention
according to Simone if you want we can
put more on that I leave the code which
you got there you can read them at home
I just want to summarize this bit and
then ruin my conclusion
disgust so I think what Simona tells us
comforts this notion of fact ich the
image being both a fact on a real
situation and some sort of fetish with
an agency of its own an image is not
only a secondary imitation reproducing
reality could be them but it's also a
direct primary and automatic and
authentic fragments of reality of the
blog of reality the symbol of an image
has a life of its own talk about quasi
organism we talked about jurors also a
German friend more like seeds virus it
inhabits us like a foreign population
it lives in us and through us it's the
image as an agency of its own we can
find a notion of automaticity
an image is an imprint according to
smooth it is the situation of which I
was a product that has been broken and I
keep an imprint as a symbol the new tree
was a decent the image is
we fragment of reality that's what we're
saying it's not a representation it's a
bit of reality of little alien reality
very women it's both hands an authentic
fact is part of reality and a magic
fetish with an agency of its own which
exceeds your control that's what that do
is very interested about is if we know
that we work with factitious we have to
worry about them when we were modern or
if we behave as modern facts we can do
whatever we want with facts we can
acknowledge with fact issues we should
be aware we don't know what they can do
they may have some unforeseen mere
oculus properties and what we know is
that they escaped from our individual
control and why that too is building the
notion of fact ich is for to push models
to behave with more care and to behave
more prudence in their interaction with
each other or with the environment
last last feature of my four pictures I
give you from the beginning the Living
Dead are the image of a living being for
also for Simona
it's a carrier of something that
emanated from
the person as alive
a relation that we could have with that
person he or she was alive which is kept
in the picture and it's this person as
alive and as for military at the end
before that just final opening arm does
this construction of the image by sea
model help us we can figure the
distinction between images and digital
images for instance this picture I
showed you earlier
currently it was taken one on the left
in the British channel on February 5th
2011 so it's a picture of what a fact
that really happened somewhere in the
British channel on that date whereas the
other picture is virtual reality
produced by computers and programs in
Saratov instead of analog and digital
photographic image on one side the way
Basner was theorizing on its ontology
and computer-generated images on the
other side
the main difference would be the
jurisdiction between an imprint
something that's printed on us I think
the briefs but Zimmerman was talking
about the symbol imprint on one side as
opposed to the program on the other side
imprints there's something about
printing gram-gram graphic it's to write
so in a way printing riding in the same
thing what difference is what's
different is the imprint comes from the
outside and prints itself on surface
program writes also trade rights with
rights towards the future or write
something that's downstream if you want
and that will take as the model of
inference what we just saw within C
model as this area the symbol of the
image a simpler
of relation and because I'm not familiar
with this domain at all but I just
discovered let my novykh's books on the
language of new media and I love it so
using this for of the operation that let
manage says are defining or specific mm
want to make it all change but not very
today but I thought was inspiring for
operations that's specific to the new
medium and we can oppose them pretty
quite easily on the inference side it's
the notion of rawness authenticity raw
reality rocks and the princes of service
as opposed to filtering in the program
in other words with filtering on the
imprint you have the encounter with an
alien with alterity with something in
that resistance that's not you and I
should be deeply with world you feel has
nothing to do with that understand
hospitality
in French maybe you know that note is
the curious word because it goes all for
the host and the guest you see little
note nobody's my guest or is my host
which other one is very confusing
because you would make you that's one of
the basic thing in languages to make a
difference between passive and active
whose host who's guest and yet I think
it's beautiful that French confuses them
and in English because if you put guests
and most its ghost nicely with my living
dead story yeah so and I think the
situation here the imprint it's a way of
making dealing with charity
it's a way to to welcome or to beware of
reality in exterior to be in the
dissimilar which is this intruder living
in me so that would be specific to the
imprint as opposed to on the program
again Manovich history on that what you
do with programming most of the time
because very few of us are programmers
actually we select from three
established menus so we can do a listing
invariate the image you can change the
curvature society consider infinite
variation and yet entry variation from
three established menus so there has
been three filtering there have been
programs that have already written that
in a way corrupt the access the
encounter with the ghost or the host or
the guest or alien being including
obviously the imprints as time fixed as
opposed to programming which can change
constant variability and clearly enough
also the analog
denouncing the ontological poverty of
the program of programming is quite
insistent of the fact that the new media
tend to offer us free established path
to follow it seems to give us an hour
freedom and yeah we can do better work
with an image is great and yet or our
menus are preset the selection are from
things that are already already
established first whereas the imprint
offers us a promise of uncharted
territory of unfiltered data maybe a
fantasy a little bit maybe something too
jarred salsa in the meeting the
programming the severan
of this relation symbol
symbol as part of the real situation
that continues to live in me with the
programming you go through a severe in
Casper separation from this relation
which diminishes the agency or the power
of the image whereas the imprint offers
us not only certain fixity from a city
but also a resistance and alterity
which we equate I think often with the
real the real is what resists to
transformation variability in certain
things
even if it's been digitized already we
can inscribe that just two or three more
smiles I think we can inscribe this in
maybe in a questioning of the notion of
authenticity and you know that is a dub
you shall stay learning every five or
six years the debate about authenticity
comes back
oh we desperately need a fantasy team
this modern world where everything is
fake and then people say oh of the
district great is what consumers want
so obviously it's recycled and used to
sell you things in the name of
authenticity and then you have Andrew
Carter coming and talking about the
authenticity ha hops all over world now
is going to pieces because we fully
should have to think about something
like authenticity and we get lost trying
to find ourselves so behind this
recurrent debate about all modern people
need something authentic to cling to
otherwise their last
a number of things we can observe is the
the thirst or the desire of the appeal
of organic food it will see that's what
we call a traceability and you want to
be chewing tough from a small vineyard
in France and not from some from some
big thing for cheese's for wine
autobiography TV reality shows all of
these can be put together in this thirst
more less desperate for authenticity now
the question is is it fundamentally
conservative is it bad because it's
conservative is it merely nostalgic
going back to the past were always sort
of sad to be modern and wish we were
more primitive or also to nature
something is it reactionary is it
ridiculous and I want to think about
what it's about harmony yeah I think
there is something conservative here
we're supposed to be this conservative
reactionary ridiculous or is it the
exploration of a particular form of
agency doesn't seem odd or maybe sketch
something which is the agency of the
image as an imprint which may be like
Xavier or maybe a certain attitude
towards photography into what the
certain colors of the imprint could be a
form of trying to recover this agency
now to operate tomorrow most light of
course it's not a matter of busy eating
that a photograph is the real period
where he was as naive when I try to
sketch the sea one was really really the
more relacin ISM is a mode of relating
to the image as an imprint but it's a
mode of relating it's not to say that
this photograph itself is reality it's a
matter of perceptual attitude this is
Stephen Briggs talk about perceptual
realism it's a matter I think very
clearly of social historical
expectations what do we expect when we
look at the picture when we go to the
movies maybe cinema as
I knew it is a historical pass a
sensitivity geared towards experiencing
this relation it's clearly a matter of
contract release contract in the novel a
referential contract in the novel a
fictional contract in the novel you may
have a relation is contract within a
certain period of cinema but I will
suggest in conclusion that it may be an
aesthetic experience a certain aesthetic
that we can cultivate and give value to
beyond the notion of authenticity as a
hoax or not as a hoax
the grave of the real nice music century
realism or sensory relation isn't for
which those music would be a model what
happened is that the digital technology
made the another distortion of sound the
scratch on record or all the white noise
on the tape
because of the digital technology that
can erase these things it transformed
noise into something that you can choose
and that you do actually enjoy
a low five low fidelity is that is in
music and film can be I think stage
investigates the same background there's
an emotion carried by the grain
I seen the grain by an enjoying the
materiality of the mediation which i
think is very far removed from any form
of ninety realism and maybe a certain
experience of cinema significantly
because France in a field would be an
enjoyment and an experience of this
grain of the reader and I just wanted to
give you four minutes of movie I really
like by Michael Monica could not go new
unknown code and just to think of you
know particularly despite avatar
computer-generated images and why not
this is not to say Oh only two movies
this way than all the rest is not
interesting obviously not because
another presentation of all the things I
gave you now and a search for some form
of authenticity which long takes the
one-shot page except for one exception
it's forty or fifty one shot takes
that's the rule of the game that
panicking gives himself which originally
are to be scattered
these are the different stories and then
you move into different spaces different
storyline and so forth and this is what
we will see just after this scene with
the cab driver similar thing to do with
the following one is Juliet finish all
we know is that she's an actress and
she's doing some testing to see whether
she will be taken in that film anout so
somebody's producing a movie because an
actress she goes there and she doesn't
know where she is the world what she's
doing she just people who are supposed
to tell her what to do so that she has a
chance to be in chosen as an actress
okay everybody
Oh
I don't know
the celebrity
who
Oh
we're here exist owners
I mean the gas or whatever there are all
these things I read you
gentlemen sumo here misshapen
it's a promoter with all pleasure also
if your question is going up
occasionally
mighty busy unknown so we need to say
that at their cover television shows up
there she fell down Joey
as you know
mm
ha
according to our research at the most it
would be special
but she said you know she's fine
and she got a rose
so thank you very much
yes
during the Impressionist era of painting
touted with our methods from a little
investigation that happened through
paintings to find evidence that had to
be transformed over to photography and
how did that change out of the advent of
photography eighteen hundreds of factors
the images that people continuously had
painted you know they don't rely on
certain elements of paintings of work
and I won't have me enter out to do
right away so anybody we don't see a lot
of pictures from the mid 19th century
we haven't image the impression late
19th century he always wanted to know
how talk the affected people's
perceptions of life around those believe
romanticized and how the element of
truth of objectivity changed
so apart from the trivial thing which is
to say that oh it's because of
photography that the impression is sir
the inside perception instead of the
external reality original thing which is
the the obvious answer and the one
that's not satisfactory because
precisely you want to see it more or
precisely what what closer interaction
there is between credibility photography
and painting and the images of ego which
is from the tears that I that I showed
earlier again it's the painting is just
as credible or as realistic and the
photograph you know it's in color so it
might seem even more realistic and yet
it's an assumption or it's us projecting
a certain contract and a certain
expectation of imprint on the
photography that generates emotions in
me for instance but as far as I know
that photograph may have been
reconstruct digitally reconstructed by
somebody who put it on the internet and
it may be taken from from the painting
ago so it's always me relating to an
image as being a photograph a photograph
being something that's a new trait and
then it produces an emotion so all these
mediations have to be really really
stored
photographing something and we're struck
by it even though we think we're seeing
it for the first time I often wonder
what is the percentage of of newness
that's really happening and how much is
brought and transformed by our memory of
the impression we draw right right right
yeah that's what that's the sign so much
business or food implanted and we're not
looking accurately we're not getting the
accurate conception of it all but rather
our history right right yeah it's
horrible
something
you look at TJ and this is I said I
wouldn't could do nurse but that's
that's the lowest main thing about
moving and God ah and all these people
in this period what we see is cliche is
cliche cliche more cliche and to produce
an image to disrupt this habit of seeing
things of knowing before seeing that we
know what you're going to see and not
seeing the thing itself but the cliche
that we have in our brain
again good and donors theorized this as
being the goal of movie making a cinema
making but achievable in very rare
occasions
I'm sorry I'm not sure I just thought it
was that I always loved that scene and I
thought it was an interesting way well
let me show you what was my my point is
I was thinking that this scene would
have no interest whatsoever if it was
made with computer-generated images so
you take avatar type of producing the
Avatar section computer-generated you
can do exactly the same dialog same save
everything and I wouldn't see any point
in doing that scene and I think that but
I don't know for me that was I wanted to
see what your reaction was so I will
return the question to you but I was
thinking this if I want to find a scene
where something happened on the filming
of the shooting of that that stays
between an actress and a camera and it
was imprinted and hanukkah insists on
the fact that doing blow cigars is this
is not so spectacular the
I saw the movie at the beginning of
Connect manuia about a ten-minute
plastic comes in the street of Paris
with six or seven characters interacting
very couple expression and he says she's
just helped to make such a movie to make
such a scene because so many things can
go wrong in ten minutes of closing costs
that it costs a lot is a headache and so
forth and yet he wants to do this
because there is some could be very late
there is reality it is real time that
and I want to put the spectator in a
position of experiencing real time so
there is this reference to reality to
relation to something that happened in
front of the camera and was printed
through on the field that is part of how
having kid conceives of making this
particular movement and I thought it was
interesting is that you had deeds you
had the performance of an actress and
the performance of an actress was to to
obviously tell us that she wasn't about
to God because she was cast as as an
actress performing something to get a
role and yet some form of anxiety or
uneasiness for me no but you go through
the scene and it's morbid fascination
with women
just abused or mistreated which is
everywhere on television it's everywhere
in the movies and this for me is one
interesting way to address it because
just terror for woman she's terrorized
and that's what we want because it's all
over
so here he shows that we know it's not
the case we know she hit me no she's
fine
what he asks her is show me your real
face I wanna see you die which is in a
way also what we want sort of staging
the desire in what we go to the movies
with what we bring to the movies or
television and stage way that's both
reality an actress performing in front
of a camera with the low fighting that
it's movie and so forth and the
Annunciation of another reality which is
what we bring before we see a picture
apparently we bring this desire because
that's what he's told to us and that's
what's on the screen it was maybe really
amateur do you
very anytime
another thing xiety is related to the
way to the long take or just because you
know it's about dying so I don't know
about the type of images so there's
something that filters through an
anxiety that again that colonizers or
brain we can't just watch this and say
all this is an actress and this is it's
part of it and we know it and yet
there's something stronger that invades
in truth or brain to make me feel very
uneasy when I see that so the charge of
reality not naive what I was interested
in is not that even we puts a number of
things that this is a movie this is
really and so forth and yeah the non
naivete of this realism and yes
discharge of reality that in spite of it
all does something including in spite of
me
are you saying that some degree fighting
let's say picking up
image slideshow
ever
you
and that you have anesthetic talking on
anesthetics that it grows the issue to
the image that is
watch out
modified and because the object of any
collisions that the digits
but we still not very clear to me and
that's because I have no context whether
we not be talking not only is writing
after sack after imagination
so and that talks about something that
was not uniting all that it was about a
bad position
I mean are you talking about
or I'm talking about
interests which is hard to be negotiated
between material set of colors and
shapes
as an image
which should be some
being friends with us
paper or away I mean all of that
suggests that the material should be
subsea material water or easily yet
please walk in
on the
Society of community or family isn't so
my reading of each theory of the image
is that he's trying to conceive of an
image that were both inside behind which
was something else
which is
in creation processes
yes
with waitthat's prehension eventually
war
as
agency
son
where's Rosalie this was not me
the image is just like I said
yeah I mean it's a very to try I'm not
that I throw white hat indirectly on him
so I don't know but I've seen the word
reaction floating there and it seems to
be and again if you go then
very precisely difference between what
has creation and
with frustrating interpretation
or manager relation basically that this
might be a question
my
and so but because when he talks about
this image of its mother one of the
strong points but that book is he says
well all these theories of
interpretation semi context of the
rhetoric of DMH or even history all
these discourses our way of simply
blocking the pure habit right
interpretation is what keeps me saying
when I see this picture the plastic arts
to a kind of freedom of interpretation
at all about cinema or Commission see
here they're these letters that means
innovative techniques and so forth so
again it's very broad sort of
ontological description of images and he
doesn't going to be deep
we bath with what you just said
mentioning impact with sort of
interpretation in the annex making
opaque
what is the real the first important
effect effective similar is one of the
theories misconception is precisely to
put the effective force at the heart to
the effect and again emphasis so this
first phase of the image the situation
in which we are I just quoted the
sensory
as important is the effective
over here or something so that's that
situation our situation in which we are
effectively invested and that's what
determines the strength of this entry
and then again when we look at images
even when they're on street or when
they're something else it's this shaft
of the NBA's charge of reality it's
vector
we have our really really interesting to
me because the kind of
more or less use that I think the three
parts
that kind of model is is acting along
that Daniel scientist
that's I mean it sounded like human
science where I work
what but the difference is that the new
science cannot do Young's effort it will
only recognize patterns of action and
will provide an analysis that you know
as the president has other future as
small doses but without the ability to
actually
there's no there's no trash it doesn't
can be a logical
because they don't when they when they
talk about image he may become athlete
let's Lucy and that's why they can't
they can't get on the psychoanalyst is a
big
images carrying effective
so it's not it may look as if the man
who talks about it whereas positive
emotion and feeling that stories will be
but if it does not it's embodied for me
and it doesn't talk it doesn't translate
into something that explained
watching this
as psychoanalysis who I dunno but it's
did anybody mourn although the ability
to work
image management
the relation noting that the function is
not something which is in me an emotion
and I think it is the relation I have
with this guest with this building with
this Sunday so relation is affect and
extremely strong position in
what interests me
ah
finish it seems to me that you defined
it as well what makes it special is the
whole like neither
somehow we use our alien life
within us and this isn't this is a
hearing
so what I'd love maybe
by not stressing defective
okay
the experiences we sort of alien
that's where yes
the
the facts in Finnish right nice try
right in the Yujin
there was
to have attention between either
changes which makes this nostalgic
or is there
well
and to
well it's not just a new projection
any messes
yeah
we need they can do some
nothing really seems to change
but on the other hand see
the trajectory that was quite
interesting they were just two things
that I want to plug in but you know
responses to play one of the
Oh
I guess you have to
something close to food in the picture
now we're asking easy the projection or
a convention for my cat I know who was
my talent I know that it's a picture I
took of my cat so I don't have any
doubts on somebody fiddling with the
digital image due around so that's why
ripped from the Internet
maybe separatist control is the picture
of a picture Tito
so this so it is a matter of belief
sometimes that belief is when entered
into arguments that can construct is a
picture Macallan or sometimes more
fragile so investing this belief that
gives it the root charge to the other
we don't need witchcraft we don't need
so maybe he's language practicing I see
Oh something happened in front of the
camera that could not be pre-programmed
by somebody with a computer better just
a character comes and reads or earrings
or Mary's pages from political theory or
pages from a tragedy in German and and
nothing I'm just brushing but
felice how is about the beauty of wind
in the trees and you could make an
avatar computer-generated you have a
function put wind in the treaty you can
do that somehow I'm projecting something
that's on probably yet which makes me
enjoy do we leave the tree I project
something a little cheese and it could
be processed for the next door
another thing I don't know
News
I think it's part of the modern
arrogance that Louise is worried about
also so to assume that we poverty of
there is only the poverty of program is
to assume that even things that print
are printed comments coming from some
form of outside for which we have this
relation of hospitality with the dangers
and the respect as part of the relation
of hospitality remain always the
negative you say that various effective
limiters can be used in politics and
national politics are just a scene with
- that was within a movie which she's
made though there you should cease from
one of them my favorite movies made to
make us
differently about crime about foreigners
about transgressing for workers about
the fears we have with this moving world
so so we need this II was sort of
utilized and became interesting for me
but we see the same type of things they
are not on television whether in
fictions or on fox news because somebody
wasn't ready but you are there
clearly I mean although I think gives us
tools to see what just nefarious effects
it has because we cannot not invest and
anxieties and fears in such images so it
spreads among us like
Oh
being still
and we definitely see this
I've read about in the cinematic image
is subjective
I
seeing that movement the first time
I see it experienced that move but at
the same time that's a moment expiry
the cigarette as as an object with
personified and he would never be closed
off so that see brother was it becomes
like a character in the film it has a
dramatic and
so there's that sort of factors
I'm sort of wondering with respect
we're off
photograph you can hold your hand
the film yo
dress
possible benefits best hi
and so its own life it's gonna be
considered you know
training was kind of seeing the agency
of objects
these are great try to explore and
thanks for green
in just a few the few ways to react
I was so these guys started many reasons
I'm just working on it now and maybe ten
people who have work and so it doesn't
mean anything to say or nobody noticed
when you read just one person noted
something which may be thing is that
story is that he is in the desert
and he sees this and obviously it's
unbelievable because this is moving so
you know the important so we will see if
you see this
we're showing a film of a movie oh
then you understand you will be fooled
but the whole situation is very we have
enemies fools in this because doesn't
look like a painting maybe a
higher-resolution baby but not like this
itself so your question can be addressed
also this way for me the fact fact and
finish will both still and cinnamon
that's why I
and discover densification because it's
even more alive because it's moving so
in this way just push this logic
were willing to merely to see somebody
that I love who happens to be here
anymore and to see how a picture vision
or something but moving and speaking and
that makes it far more intense
who shot with Russian art and one one
long take
so you
the high rates on museum
yeah